【カードをいじるはじめ】
えへぇ（ ＾ω＾）うーーー
ああっああっ（我に戻る）
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
誰かぁ
ポケモンカードに
ハマってしまいましたぁ
【拍手】
【ｽﾝｽﾝ(カードの匂いを嗅ぐ音)】
いや本当冗談抜きでやばいです
ポケモンカードにハマってしまいました
たい、大変なんですぅ
いやあのぉ ふざけてとかじゃなくて
見てくださいこれ
気付いたら
ででででーでー、そもそもなんで
ポケモンカードハマってしまったかと言うと
流れがありましてぇ、流れが
あのあのぉ、マジねあの
みんなでみんなであのぉ
っとどあー、これ今売ってるんすよこれぇ
こういうのこういうの、 こういうのが今売ってて
スタートデッキ、スタートデッキが売ってて
これ買ったらすぐポケモンカード
あの待ってそもそも 元々の話をしよう
ごめんごめん ちょっと
すいません、普通に話します
ポケモンカードにどハマりしてしまいました
はじめしゃちょーです！
まあ順を追って説明すると
全然ねぇ
あの遊ぶ気はなかったんですよ
全然やる気がなかったのに
なんかたまたまみんなであの
このスタートデッキっていうものが今売ってましてぇ
こういうのね
今ね ほのお と くさ と みず しかないんですけども
なんかいろんなタイプのデッキが売られてて
でそれで、みんな買ってやってみようって買ったら
ビックリしました！
ポケモンカード！
面白い！！！
ってぐらい、あのハマってしまいましてぇ
まぁ何がほんとすごかったって言うと
なんか試しにやってみようと思ってやったら
開始5分でルールをマスターしてしまい
なんか複雑なとこは全然分かんないんですけど
基本的なルールは なんか5分で覚えれれて
やったことなかったのに
あれぇ？これ面白いんじゃね？と思って
なんか こううぇぇーって こう
なんか たなっちとかとやってたら
なんか すごいハマってきて
気付いたら
ばかやろぉぉぉ！！！
うぇい！！
ってぐらい面白いんですよほんとに
助けてください！
いや助けないでいいんですけど
とりあえずなんか最近急にポケカブームがきちゃって
すごい大変なことになっております
はじめしゃちょーでございます
てかすごいんだよ これあのだって
デッキ1個何円か知ってる？これ
なんとデッキ1個
衝撃の500円ですよ！
ばぁろぉ！お前500円でできるんだったら
みんなやっちゃうよー！んなもん
というわけで買ったらほんとに面白くて！
あの最近みんなで
ワイワイ ポケモンカードやっております
いや面白い！ほんとねぇ
あのこれ1個だけでもすごい楽しめてぇ
闇の道を辿っております
あの皆さん知ってると思うんですけど
僕ハマりすぎるとそれしかやんなくなるんですよ
遊戯王カードのときもそうだったし
あのパズドラもやばいとき
もう他のことなんもしなくなるし
僕 何かに熱中しちゃうと
それだけしか見えなくなるんで
ちょっと...
やばい！
あとほら見てこれ あの
ダメカン、ダメージカウンターってやつ
これ例えばピカチュウがアイアンテールで
攻撃して10喰らうと
10ダメージ入るんですよ！
【SMILE】
とりあえずちょっと
ほんとハマりすぎたっていうか
もう ちなみにあの
はい！じゅんにはい！
俺何デッキ使ってるかっていうと
はがねタイプのデッキ使ってます、メタグロス
ダグトリオが強いんですよ！
ットットトン
フッ
これだけでも十分楽しかったんですけども
やっぱデッキ強くしたくなっちゃったということで
あの 今やってるゼラオラの映画の
パックが出てるんですよ、パック
それを今日ちょっと2ボックス買ったんで
これ開けて！
ちょっととテンション上げていこうと思います
えへぇ～え～～（ ＾ω＾）
とりあえずポケモンカードなにがいいかっていうとね
みんなでも分かるじゃん知ってるポケモン出ると
あのまあサブでもないんで
強そうって思ったのだけ
ちょっと見せていこうと思います
見てみなパチリスよ？パチリス
マユルドだ懐かしい
わっツンベアーだ
アイアント
ん？なに？シコシコ？
オシャマリ
ウッ↑ウッ↑うっ
やべえホワイトキュレム、ホワイトキュレム
そんな高くないでしょ たぶん
でもなんかね光ってるカードが
すごい光り方してんのがあるんだよね
おっ！おっ！
うぇぇ～これどうなんだろ
マグカルゴGX
なんかさ このねなんか
GXって付くやつが強いんだよね
まあまあ、どんどんいこう
おっ！おっ！え！？まっ待って！？
俺やばい、なんかやばい
マグカルゴに呪われてるのかもしれない
またマグカルゴです
でもなに 光り方えげつないんだけどこれ
えっ？待ってこれ技同じじゃね？
ただなんかこっちやばそう
うわぁぁぁぁん
マグカルゴが でも可愛いからね
俺はとりあえずね
ゼラオラが欲しいんだよね ぜラオラが
やべべ待ってぇ やべえ
光るカードが出なくなっちゃったあ！
せめてなんかこう
ゼラオラは出たい 出したいんだよな俺
おっおっ！あっはっっはっは！
やばいやばい
いややばいか分からないけどスイクン出た
イラストがかっこいいんだよな全部
いや これは絶対高い！
スイクンだもん
うぅあぁ～
ビリジオンGX
おあぁ～
いや別に値段がすべてって
言いたいわけじゃないんだけど
できれば高いカード欲しいよねっていう話ね
お願いゼラオラ、ゼラオラゼラオラ…
カプ・ブルル！
カプ・ブルル当たりやした！
これは流石に万越えでしょ
神様だからね、カプ・ブルルは
は！？おぉ～い
ホワイトキュレム被っちゃった これやばい
あ待って、見た見た見た
カプ・ブルル
待って被りすぎん？
ホワイトキュレムとマグカルゴと
カプ・ブルルが被ってんだけど今
おっ、出た出た出た！
サンダーマウンテン！
これ確か高かったサンダーマウンテン
サンダーマウンテン高かった確か
おぉっん
絶対安いもんヒードラン
絶対ヒードランは安い
俺 値段当てて良い？300円
やっぱりね！
わっ あぁ～！！！
ゲノセクトGX
かっけえ カードまじかっけえ！
ゲノセクト高い気がする！
はがねだから俺のデッキに入るかもしれんな
HE☆HE☆
よんひゃくぇぇん！？
（400円です）
え？これよ？これよ？
はぁっ！
ディアルガ！
ディアルガ ディアルガ
いやディアルガは伝説のポケモンなんでぇ
さすがにダイヤモンドの表紙にもなってますから
さすがに万は超えるっしょ？
ちょっと待ってこんな被るもんなん？
やばいんだけど被りが
こんな被ります？ポケモンカードって
こんなこともあろうかともう1箱買ってあります
こっちで俺はゼラオラを当ててぇ
神になり
電気デッキを作って世界を制す
開けていきまぁす！
これでゼラオラが出なかったら
ちょっぴりへこみますが
ポケモンカードはやります
うあぁ～
カプ・ブルル
待って なんかさっきと同じような流れなんだけど
はっっ！！ ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯ
出たぁ！
出た！
やばい！出た！！！
出た！出た！
ゼラオラGXです！
これねぇ、あの お店で見たんですけど
1000円ぐらいでしょ？
そんな高い？！
1,480円？！
（1,480円です）
やったぁぁぁぁぁぁ！！！！
え、めっちゃかっこいいんだけど
かっっっこいいぃ！！！
欲しい？
（欲しいです）
（は、8000円…）
か、買いますか？
俺、もう満足
もう俺いいよ
調べたんだけど
ゼラオラよりレアなカードが入ってんだよ
めっちゃ高いの
ホッ！ ホッ！？
これっ高い気がするぅ！！！多分
なんか金色に光ってるんだよねこれ
カウンターゲインという
金色に光ってます！このカード！
これやばいんじゃない、多分
（やばぁい…）
3,480円？？！！
アッ↑アッ↑！
これが！？これだよ！？
（そうですその…）
（3480円）
やばい！
やったぁぁ！
さっきのより100倍良いじゃん！こっち！
メタモン、メタモン
（1280円）
マジで！？
マグカルゴGX。
まじでポケモンカード面白くてちょっと
ハマりすぎそうでまじで怖いんで
程々にみんなでエンジョイしていければいいなと
思っております
てか500円で始められるのまじでやばいよね
ま、ポケモンカードは程よく楽しむぜ！
あっ